hey 42 here a con man named Victor
Lustig sold the Eiffel Tower
twice welcome to RIF in the mid-1960s
slumber party Barbie came with a book
called how to lose weight one of the
tips was don't eat NASA is developing 3d
printed pizzas for astronauts because
news travels so slow back then slaves in
Texas didn't know they were free for
more than two months after Lincoln
issued the Emancipation Proclamation
which declared that all slaves are
instantly freed the first escalator in
Britain was in Harrods in 1889 the trip
on the escalator was so scary for most
folks that had employed an attendant who
stand at the top of the escalator with
brandy and smelling salts to calm down
the customers after a terrifying ride
Calvin Klein's obsession for men is used
by researchers to attract animals to
cameras in the wilderness in 1962 the US
government detonated a hydrogen bomb in
space called starfish prime that was 100
times more powerful than Hiroshima in
Utah it is against the law to fish from
the back of a horse prairie dogs have
such a complex communication system that
they can accurately describe predators
with their calls they even have a
specific call for a man with her gone
Marie Curie's notebooks are still
radioactive researchers hoping to view
them more sign a disclaimer sleeping
through winter is hibernation while
sleeping through summer is estivation
the Playboy bunny costume was the first
service uniform to be registered with
the US Patent and Trademark Office
Antarctica is punishingly cold but it's
not all snow and ice about 1,200 square
miles of the continent is made up of Dry
Valleys where mountains and ridges keep
out precipitation right now over 70% of
people who are driving on highways are
speeding astronauts aboard the
International Space Station witness a
fifteen sunrises and sunsets every day
after Leonardo da Vinci's death King
Francis the first of France hung the
Mona Lisa in his bathroom thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42